hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren da heute Dienstag ist darf ich
euch natürlich recht herzlich willkommen
heißen zu einer neuen Episode Truck
Tuesday wir starten heute tatsächlich
direkt mit meinen absoluten Lieblings
tiktok an das hat auch nichts mit
Arroganz zu tun das ist einfach wirklich
unfassbar
der das also wir sind wieder die
asozialsten Schweine die sind ganz
Deutschland gibt
ich weiß nicht wie wir einer der meist
gehörten Podcasts in Deutschland sein
können was passiert mit einem Waschbären
wenn er zu viel trainiert
er wird zur Waschmaschine
was
läuft falsch bei meiner for you page
[Musik]
luca-shop.de
das ist überhaupt nicht bearbeitet
man sollte hier also in den Kommentaren
so tun als wäre es der Suchverlauf einer
Dilara wir schauen uns die Kommentare
mal an ist Nachbarland von USA USB Geld
kaufen günstig wie bekomme ich kostenlos
Make-up in welcher Stadt ist Ahmed wie
groß ist Kontinent Frankfurt Junge mit
AMG großen Haus nächste Nagelstudio das
gratis Nägel macht muss man in die
Schule für gute Noten ist Amerika
Hauptstadt in Deutschland wo kriegt man
Extensions für 0 €. wo finde ich auf
einer Deutschlandkarte Deutschland wie
viele Monate hat ein Monat wie viel
kostet das 9 € Tickets muss man nicht
Schule wenn man in Hass ist wie lerne
ich für den Schwangerschaftstest ist AMG
oder Mercedes besser Rückenschmerzen
nach AMG Rückbank was machen wie weit
ist Holland von Niederlande Shisha Bar
in der nähe ich kann nicht mehr
ich muss mich so zusammenreißen sich
nicht loslasse
[Musik]
das wäre tatsächlich auch eine Dilara
hatte
morgen ich liebe dich
du kleine [__]
no joke ich verstehe das bei so vielen
Mädels einfach in generell nicht wie man
auf einzelne Wörter so eine Bedeutung
legen kann ob ich jetzt ich dich auch
oder ich liebe dich auch sag mein Gott
diese vier Buchstaben machen keinen
Unterschied wie kann man den ganzen
generell so viel Bedeutung geben ich
check das überhaupt nicht will ich hören
jetzt komplett ausrasten ne aber voll
viele machen eine Beziehung an dieser an
diesem Worten fest und nicht nachdem an
dem fest was man gibt und das nicht also
ich kann mich eh nicht mehr raus reden
wie viel Tage hat ein Jahr
[Musik]
ich glaube
die heißt auch die Lara was wegen Monats
[Musik]
richtig Einrede nein nein
700 700
[Musik]
700 ist nah dran rate mal 750
ich kann das alles nicht mehr aber ich
bin immer noch ein intelligenter Mensch
als du denn ich muss dich nicht
beleidigen
du Stück Scheiße
die sind halt wirklich alles Sachen die
auf meiner
es tut mir leid
ich weiß doch nicht
ich weiß auch nicht ob das mehr ein Mann
war oder dieser komische Waschmaschine
Witz zu beginnen
immer wenn ich nachts am tiktok ganz
tief in diese Kamera gucke
gucke ich irgendwie wieder durch
heute gibt es die Technik verboten
Challenge das heißt keine Laptops Handys
Computer fernsehen nicht genau ich sehe
in letzter Zeit so unfassbar viele
tiktoks memes etc generell von dem
prankbros von ihren Begrüßungen mit
irgendwas witzigen drüber und da sind
immer Rechtschreibfehler drin
Bro wenn du ein bisschen weniger Zeit in
diese tiktok stecken würdest und ein
bisschen mehr Zeit in deine Bildung dann
müsstest du nicht solche tiktoks machen
[Musik]
ich muss ich wusste nicht dass sie so
dass dieser Ellbogen mäßiges dass sie so
ihren Armen dann irgendwie
[Musik]
das erste Video wo jemand was
hingekriegt hat aber dann haut der es
ist es ist
ein Wackelkontakt
[Musik]
nicht so ab ne
der war auch schon letzte Woche im Video
mit dabei
der ist immer auf meiner Folge genauso
wie diese komischen Videos wo
irgendwelche Glasflaschen von
irgendwelchen Treppen runter
[Musik]
das ist die erste Person die im heutigen
tiktok Tuesday wirklich was auf die
Kette gekriegt hat
oh man wirklich stolz drauf sein kann
Josh du hast es drauf da haben wir
wieder alle was gelernt das so
Videospiel Sounds erstellt werden früher
auch was lernen könnt ist von mir denn
ich habe es hingekriegt dass das Mädel
die ich im letzten tik tok tuese hier
auf dem Terminal drauf hatte mir
geschrieben hat sie hat mir nämlich das
hier bei tiktok geschrieben muss ich ja
Nachrichten schreiben kann als Justin
your YouTube Video über down understand
German haha was antworte jetzt
in die Kommentare was ich antworten soll
ich weiß das nicht allerdings würde
ich an der heutigen Video
abonnieren wenn es euch gefallen hat
wir befinden uns gerade im reiseanfl
[Musik]
UG nach aber mein Schiff hält nur noch
25 Sekunden das ist mein Dorf nicht mehr
sicher sie muss jetzt auf jeden Fall
noch einmal Angriff machen weil auch
gerade ein Arbeiter frei ist
schönen Tag euch